the issue that she brought up about
China the relationship between the US
and China I think is a fundamental one
people talk about the big two I think
the relationships between the US as the
world's largest developed economy in
China as the world's largest developing
economy is absolutely a critical one I
happen to be spending a lot of time in
China for work I'm doing at Harvard
Business School both in terms of
sustainable urbanization and in
executive education programs of various
kinds what I'm finding is very
interesting is an extremely high level
of interest in sustainability and
integrated reporting in China if you
look at what the official government
agencies are talking about and I forget
the exact term but the current five-year
plan is essentially one that says we
need to continue to grow we need to take
care of a large population but we need
to do so in a responsible way that takes
account of of societies limited
resources I my book on integrated
reporting is being translated into
Chinese it should be available in June
when I'm in in Shanghai in June I will
be doing a conference in collaboration
with food on School of Management
Dean John when Lu has been extremely
supportive since there's an extremely
high level of interest in sustainability
in China one of my colleagues professor
Chris Marcus is doing a study of CSR in
China and when I asked him what the
topics around CSR corporate
responsibilities are that that are high
in the list environment is clearly high
in the list you know Waters high energy
reporting around this is high sass ak
the agency that manages the the
government shares so-called people's
shares of the large state-owned
enterprises last year required the SOS
to start issuing CSR reports it's not
hard to imagine that sac would we think
about talking earlier the role of
regulation could require the SOS which
are the the dominant market cap in China
to issue integrated reports these large
Chinese companies have the assets have
the ambition they don't want to just be
big companies in China they want to be
global players and they understand that
to be global players they're gonna have
to play by global rules and they're
going to have to establish themselves as
legitimate in the global community
perhaps different standards in the US
certainly in Europe around environment
around social around labor they're smart
they get it they're adaptable and I
think you'll see tremendous change in
China in fact one can imagine in China
because it doesn't have the the same
embedded infrastructure that you would
get in places like Europe and the United
States around rules and reporting and
regulations it's not completely a green
field but it's a greener field one could
imagine that leadership around things
like integrated reporting could happen
in China and could happen in China more
quickly than it happens in the United
States in Brazil for example two of the
companies that we talked about in our
book are Brazilian there's an extremely
high level of interest in Brazil around
sustainability driven by the great
consciousness they have about the
precious resources in the rainforest and
needing to use those carefully so it
will be interesting over the next couple
of years to see as society becomes more
and more committed to I think the
awareness is there more and more
committed to society you could see
leadership being taken by some of the
major emerging market countries like
China like Brazil like India but but I
would agree with mrs. Brundtland that
the relationship between the US and
China as a is an extremely critical one
and if from the point of view of my
major mission around integrated
reporting if if the US could exercise
leadership here in the developed world
and if China could exercise leadership
in the developing world I think that
would be just terrific and the rest of
the world would probably get on board
fairly quickly